well speaking of babies a lot has
happened since the last time y'all
co-hosted with me let's take a look at
what you said just five months ago on
September 25th parents asked about
babies but not married yet I'm like wait
I don't know how you do it in Russia but
let's talk about marriage first and
operate okay I have no no okay I
definitely won't have kids and they
always act like it's so easy there's a
lot on your relationship to-do list I
like that take it slow taking right
thank you
I said take it slow Oh neither of us
work wait that was five months ago
I mean you've come back wedding and
babies so did you know at that point
that you were gonna propose I mean that
is always something in your mind yeah
but that it can happen in five months
now okay because I saw your face and I
went back and looked at the footage and
I thought maybe you had already bought
the ring at that point cuz you kind of
gave up don't ruin the surprise look oh
no ring there was no real okay you
hadn't had it yeah yeah okay so let's
talk about this ring not to put you on
this but if the I don't know if we have
turned the lights down because we're
gonna bawl gonna get blinded so where
did this come from how did you pick it
out did you know what she wanted
well actually this whole story is gonna
be on total Bella's I see she's like
should I reveal a little bit okay okay
so I took brie to a jewelry shop in
Phoenix and this guy just like poured
out this craziness in front of it and
I'm talking like drastically okay Bree
took into a very well-known drawer
because I just saw some that but so it's
like she took offered him to this guy
which I mean I love his diamond yeah so
and I really like this you know this
diamond and actually design is heading
so we are very very winter it's very
beautiful and what was your reaction cuz
the reaction is like yes I'm gonna marry
you and then like do I like my ring oh
yeah you immediately always look at the
diamond of course I loved it loved it
loved it and then I'm like I'm just I'm
obsessed with diamonds and I started
looking at I'm like autumn the salmon so
beautiful but we need to show it more
okay so bad so we may reset it okay I'm
obsessed you love it okay I love it love
it so then my next question is he
surprises you with the proposal and then
how did you tell him that you were
pregnant well we saw a little teaser and
there's like tears and yeah so I mean
that's definitely total Bella's okay I I
first took the test myself by yourself
by myself okay I was completely shocked
like I mean were you sick no I just no I
honestly just this is people or anything
I'm so weird but I literally was kept
getting these thoughts in my head to
take a test but I'm like I'm a twin I'm
feeling breathe like this has to be all
brief stuff so then I was like whatever
I'm just gonna take a test did not think
he would say positive at all and it did
and so ardham was in the dressing room
like I'm doing a suitcase and yeah he
was definitely doing a victory dance and
I put that um the test on his bag and
then he literally walked in I was like
is this yours and like no I went and
grabbed a pregnancy test but that's what
I thought I'm like yeah talk about brie
getting pregnant at the time quite a bit
and I thought like oh this is just you
know grace thing that was my initial
reaction but but we got very emotional
you did you get really crazy even though
if you're shocked and you're not ready
for it which we were not it definitely
was in you get this emotion that comes
over you that it's like oh my gosh I'm
pregnant I have this life inside of me
so you're very glowy no you really are
glowy I'm so happy and so you're a week
and a half from your sister this is
bizarro when I read this headline I
thought I can't make this stuff up this
Hollywood stuff and so but she had been
trying so she was a little upset right
well so what was crazy is brie and Bryan
were trying for baby number two for
eight months and then they just they
stopped and brie was like you know what
I just don't think we're meant to have
baby number two and Bryan was really
upset about that because I was always
their plan but accepted it supported his
wife we're good and that was it like
brie and Bryan never spoken of her
having a baby again
and
I had fun one night one night it took
for those two to fiesta in their bedroom
I don't know how else to say it that
fast in the bedroom is good only
entertainment tonight it'd be good and
Bree got pregnant
like when Bree came to me and told me
she was pregnant I was like I was I
didn't even know how to react because I
was like no no way did you know you were
pregnant Ben no you had no idea I got a
few days later and so but is this weird
to go through this as a twin like you
guys are really you're weirdos we're
weird we are we're weird
never in my life like I've been seen
like people putting out there like oh
they totally did IVF and all this like
do people even know a serious IVF is
like it's a major surgery right um I
never thought in my life that Bree and I
would ever even have kids within a few
years apart because even when I was here
five months ago I mean I did not think
we were gonna get pregnant for a long
time yeah so now to be a week and a half
apart it's crazy to me it's mind-blowing
but I have to say I actually like it
yeah because Brees my encyclopedia I go
to her on the daily every day about
everything cuz I look at birdie and I'm
like she turned out great
so I'm gonna follow you and it's kind of
been like really fun I just don't feel
alone in this process
yeah and we have the same cravings the
same symptoms like same everything and
how did she take the news
how'd you take the news item um let's
just say not extremely positive at first
she was upset
we'll work our way we worked and then it
was great and now it's amazing
but brie does say the least was
extremely shot right she was just like
wait you just got engaged and now you're
pregnant and I I just don't know what's
going on in your life
like like why was she shocked like are
you happy for you yeah you know there's
and I don't want to give too much we act
as total Belles to catch so much our
life that happened within two and a half
months and we were on a rollercoaster
ride and you know you go to your sister
and you vent about stuff right so then
all of a sudden when you know why do you
sisters take Benteen so seriously I'm
like I come to you to gets up off my
chest right were you too
make an opinion I'm just worried she was
worried so it wasn't that she was mad at
you for being pregnant she was just
worried about you
yeah she was exactly that okay so you
guys are good now oh my gosh like so
good she's in town right now they've
been taking over the house for the past
because she didn't like you at the
beginning either you've had to jump on
many always go through the same like a
cycle of things yeah it's like oh no and
then okay alright so yeah okay alright
so next thing I know that you guys found
out the baby's gender last week and I
was just wondering if you wanted to
share that with Entertainment Tonight
right now because it's not like we have
anything planned here on set we don't
have you know a lovely anything like
this you know what color strikes your
fancy at this moment that is really um
blue okay you know at first you know
Artem and I had discussed this yeah we
were like we of course when we find out
her gender we want to share with
everyone but then the producers side of
me yeah I love cable TV and I'm like
what surprises do we get left in the
world for cable TV that isn't already
showcased in social media yep so our
demand I discussed with everyone and
we're like you know we really want to
save it for total Bella's so we actually
could have surprises that draw people to
the episode yeah Game of Thrones
we didn't right gonna die every week it
was ice lady the baby is Jon Snow right
or something not a finger or the
bachelor like Crichton is still someone
champagne it's so excited of like the
drama every week so will you do a big
like reveal oh we went full out oh
you've already taped old oh yeah oh okay
so you ate the cake and the balloons and
all that stuff oh we went better okay
okay
we it her it was so fun okay you did it
so cool and so we figured you know for
fans and our viewers we're gonna save it
yeah because we had a massive buildup
cuz we had to wait so long yeah I'm like
I'm getting them a massive buildup okay
yeah well no in June now here's my
question do you know what your sisters
having no and they're gonna wait they're
gonna wait until yeah baby's born
yeah
when flames okay um names you're screwed
because you're gonna have a Russian name
and it's gonna be impossible to spell
middle okay so we tell them the story
about the middle name the story about
the Russian names typically we always
say first a family name yep
then your first name and then your
middle name but the middle name we don't
just pick and choose the middle name
comes from our father so my dad is
Vladimir so my mule name is
Vladimirovich yeah so let's say if it
will be a girl for example right it will
little baby flatter Mitch
no because gonna be asking my name my
name is Artem so my baby's girl middle
name is gonna be out of Tamia vicha but
if it's a boy then I became you for the
boy and that can be enough for the girl
so yeah it's like my name Artem yeah but
who the [ __ ] and then artemyevich or
out of time here but now you spell that
arte M & Veatch invent the Russian dad
can I ride the spell that's interesting
are you gonna continue this tradition it
seems like it means a lot to him but
it's a lot I mean we're not getting a
birdie May right it was hard for me cuz
I was like well they're already getting
your Russian last name like can I have
two American names in the Friday but it
was such a weird hybrid name that's
light makes no sense well but I do
respect traditions yeah traditions in my
family so it will be a Russian middle
name and last name and I'm just gonna
have to get a Russian tutor and learn
how to say my kid's name because I can't
just you seemed thrilled about it she's
like it's gonna be uh yeah like he can't
smell it so imagine me or imagine with
my kids like two or three and it's
yelling at me in Russian and I'm like I
don't even know yeah let me get Google
Translate we gotta find we got a few
months to figure this out guys but you
know for a girl I always say Kelty is a
great name tom is very Dancing with the
Stars so you're heading to the Bahamas
yeah yeah anime so is that where you'll
have your babymoon cuz I know I was
actually gonna go and dance I was gonna
go join them but it's just not safe for
me at that time
we couldn't tell when they were doing
the whole deal yeah and they wanted me
to come with our demand artem really
wanted me to join I already knew I was
pregnant as early but I was like I just
to take that chance it yeah there's me
you don't want to do it so you're just
gonna head off for a month by yourself
to the Bahamas it's just like a weekend
okay
oh so you're fine yeah just going and
then you'll be back yeah and then can
you do a babymoon will you take time off
oh yeah I totally and we're gonna do a
dual wine with brand brand oh you're
gonna do a sister sister baby but you
know that okay I'm like if I can't drink
I need my partner in crime there and any
news about dancing the stars in the fall
um no we literally haven't heard a you
haven't heard anything would you
the doors open though right except
you're gonna have a brand new baby at
home yeah
and I feel like he's open I we're having
our baby in LA and I told our time if he
ends up dancing next season I will
breastfeed and watch and support right
come to the ballroom everyone loves a
baby story - it's good TV good - Artie
Hilton's story
[Music]